what made you say about Alex yes you're
the person I want to spend the rest of
my life with what are the qualities it
was it was different it was different
than anything I had ever experienced
Jennifer Lopez is revealing how she knew
Alex Rodriguez was the one his
consistency like what he says he does
mmm every time and that you know it's
big big you know and he also wanted he
wants to build together which I've never
had I've never had you know somebody who
wants to see me shine and grow and be I
think him being my life was a big part
of what happened this year Wow
I mean because he allowed me to kind of
just like and it wasn't like get back
down here the singer and actress was
with Oprah Winfrey for her 20/20 vision
your life in focused tour where she also
got candid about her fiance's
relationship with her kids specifically
his special bond with 12-year old Max
saying quote I remember this
conversation with max even though it's
like three years ago now he said
something like Alex is the only one who
ever doesn't ever get mad at me the mom
of two went on to explain that max tends
to be the one who gets in trouble around
their house and alex has had amazing
patience with him
[Music]
recently the proud mom posted this
adorable clip of her son and his
school's production of The Wizard of Oz
while chatting with Oprah she gushed
about how even though Max is all over
the place
he is the most beautiful boy and the
most loving boy during the sit-down JLo
also revealed how she really felt after
not getting an Oscar nomination for her
role as Ramona and Hustler's did you
feel snubbed when people start saying
you were snubbed for the Oscar didn't
sad because there was a lot of build-up
to it
yes so many or I got so many good
notices yeah more than ever in my career
and I'm reading all the articles and I'm
going oh my god could this happen and
then it didn't it was like ouch it was
it was a little bit of a letdown oh so I
felt like my whole team like I said most
of my team has been with me for years
2025 years and I think they had a lot of
hopes on that like they wanted it to
yeah and I felt like I let everybody
down a little bit the 50 year old went
on to admit that she was seeking
people's validation and soon realized
that she doesn't need the award to tell
her that she is enough
last month et spoke with Jennifer at the
Independent Spirit Award where she
assured fans that the end of award
season doesn't mean the end of Ramona's
run
a warrant season but it's definitely not
the end for Ramona when you gave her a
nod at the Super Bowl folks lost their
mind when you climbed up on them that
boat it was but you know it was such a
skill to have learned and I just knew
that at this time that it would be a fun
thing for the audience
[Music]